hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I am
here at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas
honored to be joined by the great John
Mackey of Whole Foods you've been
interested in libertarian causes and
thought for a long time you've also been
part of this incredible kind of
revolution in the way that we talk and
think and interact with food over the
years and and the politics of food I
think have become pretty interesting in
this country as part of that be adjusted
to get in your take it seems to me and
maybe I'm wrong that a lot of the same
kind of energy or the same kind of
people who've been interested in the
sourcing of food and and and being more
conscious about where we where we get
and how we process food particularly
some of that energy then goes into kind
of restricting the choices or banning
certain practices it doesn't have to
lead to that but there seems to be
something in human nature that wants to
restrict other people's choices some
people are seem to not be happy unless
they're telling other people what to do
that they know best and that so that's
always discouraging do you or Whole
Foods get involved in these kind of
fights as they play out politically or
are you more interested in in the
consciousness-raising aspect of it
we're more interested in the
consciousness-raising aspects of it
we've occasionally waded into certain
political battles like we've been
involved in getting organic standards
into law and and we felt like there were
inconsistency wasn't a level playing
field of people were cheating so we
thought having consistent organic
definitions and everybody playing by
those rules would probably be a good
idea and I think on balance it has been
a good idea but of course there problems
with it and
Organic itself is highly politicized
Whole Foods is you very frequently
criticized most recently the New York
Times for being a you know one of the
big corporations that is corrupting
organic and just because we're large a
lot of suspicion and mistrust is because
there's such an anti corporation
mentality by a lot of people in the
country uh and I mean just because
you're successful corporation is it that
they they're charging that that you are
kind of a bogus you're well the next you
have to understand the narrative that
many people have about business and
capitalism is that they're fundamentally
selfish and greedy and exploitative in
corporations are sociopaths that they
don't care about anything or anyone but
themselves and make it as much money as
possible so therefore they cannot be
trusted and they become too powerful and
then they they bribe people and they
they sell poisonous things and they're
fundamentally evil and of course I don't
agree with that narrative and in fact
you have a book coming out later this
year talking about this tell us a little
bit about it what's the title
well capitalism of course itself has
been amazing it's been a first chapter
in the book is extraordinary success or
capitalism the second chapter is why
isn't capitalism better left and we put
forth a thesis that it we need a new
narrative for we need to think about
business differently that business asks
the possibility to have a higher purpose
besides just just making money there's
nothing wrong with making money but
that's not particularly inspiring and
every other profession in the world from
doctors teachers engineers architects
lawyers if you ask what their purpose is
it refers back to some type of
contribution they're making to other
people and business is the greatest
value creator in the world business
creates value for its customers for its
employees for suppliers for its
investors for the larger communities
it's part of their the value creators we
are the value creators we're the heroes
and yet that's not the narrative this
told about business so we're telling
that NER
and at the same time we're challenging
business to be more conscious and to
take their value creation to a higher
level and understanding that all of
these stakeholders they're creating
value for connected together and so you
ought to strategically organize your
business in such a way that you can
optimize value for all of those
stakeholders Fred Smith of the committed
Enterprise Institute frequently kind of
bemoans the fact that capitalists and
entrepreneurs are no longer selling that
story that heroic story about themselves
and are not interested in in
contributing to the discussion over all
of the benefits of capitalism in the
same way that you know we might remember
them doing in the 1950s and 1960s there
seem to be more kind of let's just talk
about the underlying principles here do
you share that kind of critique out
there or what's what's your take on the
I we have a section in the book where we
talk about how the intellectuals hijack
the narrative of capitalism in business
and you can go back to I mean Adam Smith
wrote two great books for wealth of
nations and the Theory of Moral
Sentiments he synthesized together those
together and you have a of self-interest
and you have empathy and care and
sympathy for others and you have the
foundation for a great economic system
but intellectuals and economists ignored
that ethical foundation of capitalism
and they tried to ground it on strict
self-interest and that led to ethical
attacks
I mean Marxism fundamentally is an
ethical attack on capitalism is
fundamentally wrong and evil and that's
it and then the economists even the
defenders of capitalism played into
trying to defend it strictly on the
basis of the decree it creates wealth
and but not its ethical foundation of it
unless you do a Randian type of ethical
foundation that it is about
self-interest and that's great
unfortunately that hasn't sold very well
to most people it and so we're trying to
change that narrative and
get people to realize the type of value
that business creates so the narrative
of business being fundamentally greedy
and selfish and exploitative that
undermines business's standing in
society and it can't be defended it has
to be defended on an ethical basis not
just on the fact that it creates wealth
that's great thank you john mack from
Whole Foods Matt Welch from recent TV